the poor were here at London Film Comic
Cons a day it's great to see you've been
enjoying about the event so far it's
sociable this is what I like it's bit it
can be a bit relentless but II like
signing your name a thousand and odd
times that can be a little bit
relentless have you ever written your
name over and over and over and over and
over
cuz it morphs into something else mine
currently is it was Pam Ferris for about
two hours then Phil Collins and now it's
there is it no Paul Newman I like it a
man of many guises a well man of many
guys on yeah exactly yeah
Madame's that lot long journey a man of
a thousand faces yeah of course I'm sure
lots people been talking to you about
Doctor Who today what your favorite
memory to me your time in the TARDIS
consider it was only six weeks I was
talking over six weeks whenever it was
seventeen years ago so it was brief I
can't remember that much apart actually
to be perfectly honest I can remember
cuz cuz our children were little I can
remember them being around I can have a
lot of green screen stuff I remember
kissing Daphne ashbrook and having to
put having to glue a wig onto my head
everyone me hair was really short about
this long underneath it and they freaked
out so they put this full wig on my head
every morning I'm gonna look at it now I
can see you know a bit like having been
botoxed I didn't quite have all the
expression I probably could have used
what was that light really having to do
that every day that you oh my god
it's a pain in the ass to be perfectly
honest and um I was a bit of a vanity
buster as well I thought I looked cool
and I said to them cuz I just played
this Soulja Boy part and I said come on
man I said Doctor Who should look a
little bit tasty a little bit tough and
why don't I wear a leather jacket and
they said absolutely no way so they said
no my doctor who's gotta be like you
know soft and wearing a cravat and B so
as soon as like Chris Eccleston turns up
seven years later whatever it was
what does he had like buzz cus leather
jacket I was gutted
stole my alerts tommy 'thunder what do
you think of this our new generation of
Doctor Who they've certainly got
prettier a little bit more symmetrical
I'm not bitter a little bit more
symmetrical a little bit cleverer than
we were but it's great it's really
exciting in it
you know I'm when we did that movie
pilot whatever you call it just sixteen
seventeen years ago you know it could
have been that doctor who would die then
it could have been over and now it's
inconceivable it looks good for another
hundred years you know so we did
something right I like to think that you
know that we needed vindicate but we
were part of the reason perhaps why it
never quite disappeared and although it
was nine ten years later you know we
were perhaps partly responsible for its
returning I like to think so anyway and
here we are in the fiftieth anniversary
year as well I mean you kind of a fan of
Doctor Who you ideas about what you'd
like to see in the show to be perfectly
honest with you I was never a fan not
like because I now I know what fans
ah what constitutes our firm I mean we
watched it as kids you know I was a kid
in the 60s and everyone watched it
because there was only three channels
everybody wanted it but I was never
around yeah Ralph McTell I rest my case
Ralph it I've turned into Ralph McTell I
just think it's great what's happened
and particularly like great Eliot Peter
Capaldi's gonna take over proper fan
brilliant actor lovely man incidentally
later like David Tennant Matt Smith so
it's in good hands you know do you think
Peter will bring to the show
I think you've bring the kind of
old-fashioned scary gravitas that my
favorite William Hartnell had you know
he'll bring some of that I think was
probably about time that
they went back into a middle-aged doctor
again I'm not bitter but I'm healed
he'll bring a real like I say a fierce
intelligence in a and a fatherly thing
because that's also part of it you know
doctor who is the doctor is he said met
these many-faceted you know he's this
fugitive almost adolescent sometimes but
doesn't you know you look at William
Hartnell and certainly what's-his-name
who flew around the North Circular in a
hovercraft Jon Pertwee didn't know that
did it and with Miss Walthamstow 1974
John purty was the same he he had that
proper gravitas I think Peter will have
that I think it's in great hands it in
safe hands hopefully he'll swear like a
trooper like Malcolm said I think we're
all secretly hoping that email took her
in there definitely I'd love to see that
I mean obviously there's still lots of
speculation going on as we near the date
for the 50th anniversary special 23rd of
November so we 50 days away now this
50th I was a bit dismayed because I
always wanted to be in a 3d anything
even like jaws through though I would
love to have been in any old thing any
old rubbish so I was a bit gutted when I
heard that you know that's what it was
gonna be like but no no there's no McCoy
there's no you know we're not in it
we're not nor are we in the Christmas
special let me tell I don't think so
anyway not unless you're going to shoot
it next week but there's all kinds of
rumors and counter rumours and
everything doing the rounds but one gets
tired of trying to refute things on
Twitter and the like but take it from me
I'm not in it
we love we would have liked you to be in
it obviously but we know we've heard it
for the horse's mouth now yeah but to
think about the doctor and doctor who of
course is that if not now then maybe
some other time you know because that's
that's the beauty of it you know we can
always come back
and what about as well and being on a
50th anniversary stamp this year as well
how did he feel rather huh
you know what I was yeah I was I was
honored it's an honor of course to be
understand to be alive and to be honored
on a British town is it honor one of my
sons actually was was absolutely
thrilled by it he said dad that's got to
be the most that's gotta be the most
impressive thing that you've ever done
and I never thought about like that but
you know ways right you also cause been
doctor in audio plays as well what's
that like going from the sound stage to
just the sound booth
I love radio I love audio you know I not
be happy to continue for as long as they
want to on audio
I think audio was great you know a lot
of actors do oh hey you can wear your
own clothes and you don't have to learn
the line so does that but it's really
it's sociable and and it's a hoot you
know to do them and of course I'm most
of the word most of the imaginative work
it's done by the audience here you have
to you have to properly engage with it
it's more than natural it's more than
just about a look the way that you look
you know so it's fun I love that it's in
a Ministry of chances that you've done
recently as well and that's to be film a
chance is a bunch of audios but in
couple of weeks we shoot the first bit
of of a full-length feature it's gonna
be an ongoing process we're gonna have
to shoot the first button and try and
get funding for you know the next stage
of it but I'm watch this space that
would be good who else isn't that with
you I don't know I don't know it seems
to change every day I know I'm I heard
that Tim McInerney is gonna be my
nemesis all my father I think and then
end up with E McCoy's in it
but also there's going to be people in
it that have contributed to the making
of it which is quite a good idea you
know so if you are in somewhere
responsible or even just sends a bit of
money and you can be in the thing yeah I
think it's a good idea we've enjoyed
speaking to here thanks so much for your
time Paul my pleasure it's been lovely
talking
you